democrats and the media connect border
enforcement to white supremacy
democrats lay out their policy proposals
proposals and joe biden flubs it like i
just did i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
uh we have a lot to get to this hour joe
biden obviously stepping on his own toes
some people are trying to attribute that
to racism in all likelihood it's just
because joe biden isn't under head
we'll get to all of that in just a
second we begin today however
with the gradually creeping attempt by
so many people in the media
and on the left to define out the
borders of white supremacy to
contain anything they don't like and
this is such a mistake it's such a
mistake because again
white supremacism is a thing a very
dangerous thing the alt-right is a thing
it's a dangerous thing and it's a
terrible thing
and these things have specific
definitions white supremacists believe
that white people are inherently
superior white nationalists believe that
white people should be separate from
members of other races
all of this cuts against the fundamental
bases of western civilization
and the american revolution and the
constitution of the united states
it cuts against the idea of a more
perfect union in which the rights that
were guaranteed by the declaration of
independence are broadened out
appropriately
to more and more people over time as
they have been throughout american
history
through blood and pain and toil and
through tears and difficulty and
suffering
all the ideology of white supremacy is
existent it's evil and it has malignant
effects
not just on the body politic more
generally but has malignant effects when
it comes to
violence that sometimes attends white
supremacists as we saw in this white
supremacist terror attack
in el paso but being specific about our
definitions
allows us to create unity nearly all
divisions in life
come from inability to be clear about
the terms that we are defining when you
have a fight with your spouse half the
time it's because you're not
understanding each other you're seeing
right past each other you're talking
right past each other the same thing is
true in business when you have business
disputes usually it's because there was
lack of clarity at the very beginning
being clear about the definition of
terms is what allows us to be on the
same side it's what i've always said
about the left's take on quote-unquote
institutional racism if the left wants
to point out
a policy that is racist i will fight it
along with them if the left is going to
point to a disparity and then just blame
quote unquote institutional racism
racism that is just out there mismatic
hovering out there in the universe then
no i can't be with you because that
doesn't have a definition
especially if i believe that you are
going to use your definition-free
property
in order to attack people that you just
disagree with politically
we saw this yesterday with alexander
ocasio-cortez and her long tweet thread
about white supremacy in which she talks
about the evils of white supremacy how
it's a virus
how you could be subconsciously a white
supremacist or suffering from white
supremacy how even if you are
anti-racist
you could be suffering from white
supremacy how it's a virus that lies
dormant
you may not know that you're a carrier
it was all deliberately vague
and the reason it was deliberately vegas
so it could be broadened out and applied
to people so they could be tarred by aoc
and her allies
as racist and white supremacists this is
a pattern the media have been doing it
for years
folks on the political left have been
doing it for years and the latest
example
the latest example is the left's attempt
to
paint immigration enforcement as white
supremacy
so i am very much libertarian on
immigration in a perfect world in a
perfect world
where it's not about becoming a citizen
it's just about coming in free flow of
labor people moving in and out to work
i really don't have a problem with
people moving in and out of countries
to work like the freedom of travel
provisions that they have in the eu
are not terrible provisions so long as
there's some level of cultural
assimilation
to the country in which you move there
are certain factors that militate free
and open immigration
those include assimilating to the
culture into which you move
making sure that you're not on welfare
payments right there are certain things
that militate against that but free and
open immigration served the united
states quite well
particularly in the early 20th century
when waves of immigrants were coming in
being assimilated not reliant on welfare
okay with that
said being strong on immigration right
now particularly on our southern border
and ensuring that the people who come
through are processed correctly that
they are not falsely claiming asylum
that they are going to be benefits to
the united states and not detriments to
the united states
that they are coming in to assimilate
and become part of american culture and
be part
of the great american dream right that
is something we need to do
we do need to distinguish who is coming
across our border because any country
any sovereign country
has to be in control of who gets to
enter the country this has been true for
every country
throughout the history of the world and
whenever people cite the bible and say
well you have to treat the stranger well
of course you have to treat the stranger
well one of the provisions
of the bible is also that strangers have
to treat you well i mean they're
supposed to come in
and respect the sovereign entity into
which they are moving obviously
so folks who are saying we need stronger
border policing particularly
because there are high crime areas along
the border in which drug cartels have an
enormous amount of sway
because there are people coming into the
country who are disproportionately
reliant on welfare programs because
they're disproportionately poor and
disproportionately undereducated
right all of that all of that militates
against a free and open border
that would exist in the utopian
libertarian world of
the imagination of libertarians okay so
being tough on the border does not mean
that you're a white supremacist notice
nothing about this has to do with race
not a single word i have said here has
to do with race because it doesn't have
to do with race
i wouldn't care if we bordered a poor
country on our southern border
that was white it doesn't make a
difference to me if there are people who
are crossing the border
who shouldn't be crossing the border
then of course we should make sure that
we have better border enforcement
what the left is attempting to do now is
broaden out
the the white supremacist label so they
can include within it anybody who is
tough on immigration
and this just underscores that they
don't actually take white supremacism
particularly seriously on the radical
left
if they did they would be specific about
targeting it so we could all fight it
it's like going to a doctor and the
doctor knows that you have cancer
but instead of just giving you the
treatment for the cancer the doctor says
you have a condition and you say well
what condition do i have that says
doesn't matter the broad treatment
is a broad spectrum of things that i
want to do to you and charge you for
you say well right but what do i have so
we can fight it together so we can
decide on the treatment together
it actually doesn't matter what you have
it's bad okay this is not helpful
not only is it not helpful it's hurtful
because it allows malignant white
supremacism
to creep into the mainstream see what
one thing that white supremacists want
and if you've spent any time
looking at the materials that they
distribute which i have since they
target me personally
what you see is they are constantly
looking for a broader ship to latch onto
they are leeches
their barnacles and they clamp on to
broader ships and then they try to
pretend that the broader ship
is them right they've done this with
trump this is why you see white
supremacist groups abroad wearing maga
hats it's not because
they agree with everything donald trump
says it's because they want the media
and members of the left to believe
that donald trump is the leader of their
movement so they seem broader and larger
than they are and when the left
suggests that everyone is a white
supremacist secretly that everyone
is on board with the that the white
supremacist position is the
hard on illegal immigration position and
that everybody who embraces that
position is secretly a white supremacist
what they're actually doing
is giving all sorts of credibility and
credence to white supremacists
which is what white supremacists want
white supremacists want people to
believe disaffected young men
to believe that they are they are more
powerful
and more influential than they are and
that they are speaking truths that
others just don't want them to hear
right their goal is to make it seem as
though they are an underground group of
people
who have spread their tentacles
throughout the ideologies of mainstream
american society
but are really speaking the truths
underlying those tentacles
and the left right now is pushing that
agenda at least in
insofar as as exacerbating the reach of
white supremacists by linking it with
mainstream policy
that's a huge mistake it's a huge
mistake well a second we're gonna get to
how
so many members of the left i think many
of them unintentionally are doing this
with regard to illegal immigration
but first maybe your sleep quality has
been bad this week let me tell you my
sleep quality has not been
great this week because of the news but
when the news cycle is not keeping me
awake
i want to make sure that i am sleeping
on the best mattress possible
because let's face it i'm bad at sleep
but one of the things that has made me
better at sleep is my helix sleep
mattress
helixly personalizes a mattress just for
you helix sleep has a quiz that takes
just two minutes to complete
it matches your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress no
matter how you sleep
side back hot sleeper whatever helix can
make what your body needs just go to
helixsleep.com take their two minute
sleep quiz they will match you to a
customized mattress that will give you
the best sleep of your life
for couples helix can even split that
mattress down the middle providing
individual support needs
and field preferences for each side
they've got a 10-year warranty you get
to try it out for 100 nights at
risk-free
they'll even pick it up for you if you
don't love it but you will so i mean
what do you have to lose here
it really is fantastic my wife and i
took the two minutes sleep quiz the
mattress arrived in the mail
we just cut open the box it inflated
right in front of us we popped it on the
bed frame we're good to go it's so good
i got one for my sister for her wedding
helix right now is offering up to 125
bucks off all mattress orders for our
listeners get up to 125 bucks off at
helixsleep.com that's helixsleep.com go
check them out right now helixsleep.com
for up to 125 bucks
off your mattress order okay so how are
the
how are members of the media attempting
to broaden out
the white supremacist label well they're
attempting to do it
with regard to illegal immigration
particularly surrounding a raid that
just happened in morton mississippi
so listen to how the associated press
reports this u.s
immigration officials rated seven
mississippi chicken processing plants on
wednesday
arresting 680 mostly latino workers in
the largest workplace sting in at least
a decade now
this is nothing new under george w bush
there were workplace stings
and there was a very famous one in
postville iowa that resulted in the
arrest of several hundred illegal
immigrants
so workplace raids that are designed to
go after employers
who are employing illegal labor those
have long been a part of american life
this is part of law enforcement
sometimes you raid businesses that are
violating the law
the raids were planned months ago they
happened just hours before
president donald trump visited in el
paso texas the majority latino border
city where a man linked to an online
screed about a hispanic invasion
was charged in a shooting that left 22
people dead
okay so look how the ap is trying to
link together the white supremacist
shooting
with basic u.s immigration enforcement
and the trump administration
and then they quote angelica sales
executive director of the coalition for
humane immigrant rights
saying quote on a day when we seek
unifying words and acts to heal the
nation's broken heart
president trump allows so many families
and communities to be torn apart
about 600 u.s immigration and customs
enforcement agents fanned out across the
plants operating
operated by five companies surrounding
the perimeters to prevent workers
from fleeing and then all of the media
attention has focused in
on the family members who are left
behind who are not caught up
in the raid at the ap says those
arrested were taken to a military hangar
to be processed for immigration
violations
about 70 family friends and residents
waved goodbye and shouted let them go
let them go
later two more buses arrived a tearful
13 year old boy whose parents are from
guatemala waved goodbye to his mother a
coke worker
as he stood beside his father some
employees tried to flee on foot but were
captured
in the parking lot mississippi is the
nation's fifth largest chicken producing
state and the plant's tough processing
jobs have mainly been filled by latino
immigrants
eager to take whatever work they can get
chicken plants dominate the economies of
morton and other small towns
east of jackson matthew albans ice's
acting director told the ap in an
interview on wednesday
just down the road from the coke plant
that the raids could be the largest ever
workplace operation in any single state
asked about their coinciding with
trump's visit to el paso albans
responded this is a long-term operation
that's been going on
he said raids are racially neutral and
based on evidence of illegal residency
he said that the companies involved
could be charged with knowingly hiring
workers who are in the country the
county illegally
and will be scrutinized for tax document
and wage fraud
bill chandler then they start quoting
folks saying that basically this is
racist
bill chandler executive director of the
mississippi immigrant rights alliance
calls the terrible raids another effort
to drive latinos
out of mississippi and blame trump for
fanning racism with past incendiary
comments
about immigrants so there's an attempt
now to tie basic border policy
that trump is espousing to white
supremacy
and you can see this in the media
coverage there's this massive raid
and the focus isn't on illegal
immigrants being
being arrested for violating the law the
focus
is on the effect on the families the
idea is if we show enough crying
children on tv
after people are arrested for violating
the law then we will shift to the policy
it's you don't see these sorts of
stories after there's a big drug bust
for example after there's a big drug
bust cocaine ring people are dragged
away to jail
you don't see them focus in on the kids
still standing there waiting for mommy
or daddy to come home
when kamala harris is rounding up truant
parents in california's attorney general
you're not seeing videos about the kids
who are left at home and the every
arrest ends with a parent going to jail
if there are kids in the picture
but the media are focusing heavily on
this for a specific reason here is cnn
focusing
on kids weeping after the ice raids
again it's
terrible that this is happening to the
kids
their parents also violated the law two
things can be true at once
here's cnn reporting on this
[Music]
taking away crying children left without
parents after immigration
in immigration raids across mississippi
on wednesday i need my dad for me
my dad didn't do nothing he's not a
criminal
many children left behind at schools and
day cares
one gym in a nearby town offering to
house and feed children who were
separated from their parents
i understand the law and how everything
works but and everything has a system
but
everybody needs to hold the kids first
and foremost in their mind
okay well i agree the kids will also be
held first and foremost in
minds but is there any question that if
barack obama had had
arrested people and then separated them
from their children that the media would
have ignored it
that wouldn't have been the top line
story this of course is the top line
story because trump is president
and because there are a lot of folks in
the media and on the left who are trying
to promulgate a narrative that the real
reason trump is doing this
is out of racial animus and it's not
just members of the media who are subtly
pushing this some people are just saying
it openly sheila jackson lee
congressperson from texas
she comes out and she suggests that
these ice raids are like gestapo
i am on homeland security um i think
it's unfortunate when ice
has to be made into this kind of agency
uh
and to be an intimidator rather than an
agency that has in the past made sure
that we are safe in this nation
that is what americans want to be safe
but when their neighbors are rounded up
in a vile way when children are left
unprotected i'm disappointed and the
president
uh and steve miller need to stop these
gestapo tactics and we need to work
together
to pass comprehensive immigration reform
the gestapo tactic he's like a nazi an
immigration policy is nazi-esque
this is exacerbated of course by a piece
in today's new york times
it was on the front page of their
website called quote it had nothing to
do with us
restrictionist groups distanced
themselves from accused el paso shooter
who shared similar views on immigrants
so in other words because the el paso
shooter
talked about the dangers of immigration
and did so in the most vile racist
possible way
he is basically just an offshoot of
general immigration restrictionism
okay which is somewhat like saying that
because the congressional baseball
shooter
was angry at republicans over health
care policy that he is definitely an
offshoot
of generalized upset over america's lack
of proper health care
right no that's not how this works so
the new york times explicitly
trying to link mainstream
anti-immigration groups
i don't agree with some of their
policies fair and and
and some of the other groups that are
cited here numbers usa
but the notion that those groups are
linked to the mass shooting in el paso
again this is what the media are trying
to do to broaden out the concept
which is that white supremacy really
isn't just somebody who
declares that white people are superior
and that america needs to remain white
and then shoot up in el paso at walmart
white supremacy is really anybody who
believes that there ought to be
immigration restrictions
right so the new york times has this
piece linking these groups who are not
linked
with the shooter to the shooter and then
the media decide that they're going to
cover immigration
such that if you are if you are in any
way a restrictionist
on illegal immigration then you are
inevitably linked to an underlying
racial hatred and this is disgusting
stuff
it divides americans for no reason
because again
there is a bad guy out there there are
bad people out there there are actual
white supremacists out there but linking
generalized conservative policies on
immigration to white supremacism
is overtly dishonest we'll get to this
new york times piece
in just one second first let's talk
about that credit card debt you've been
racking up so you've been racking up
all sorts of credit card debt and you
think to yourself okay i'll pay it off
and then you fall one month behind and
soon enough you are paying 29
interest rates and your life is
basically ruined financially well
you don't have to do that okay if you've
racked up some credit card debt and you
want to get out of that
maybe you ought to contact my friends
over at lending club lending club
allows you to consolidate your debt or
pay off credit cards with one fixed
monthly payment
lending club has helped millions of
people regain control of their finances
with affordable fixed rate personal
loans no trips to a bank
no high interest credit cards just head
on over to lendingclub.com
tell them about yourself and how much
you want to borrow pick the terms that
are right for you if you're approved
your loan is automatically deposited
into your bank account in as little as a
few days
lending club is the number one
peer-to-peer lending platform with over
35 billion dollars in loans issued
it is really easy to fall into debt but
there's no reason that you have to stay
there
go check out lendingclub.com check your
rate in minutes
borrow up to 40 grand that is
lendingclub.com
lendingclub.com ben all loans made by
web bank member fdic equal housing
lender lendingclub.com
slash ben go check them out right now
make sure to use the slash benz that
they know
that we sent you okay so as i say the
new york times has this long piece
trying to link
those groups that are just on policy
immigration restrictionists
with the racist white supremacist
sentiments of the el paso shooter
david nakamura writing this egregious
piece hours after the mass shooting in
el paso last weekend
dan stein president of the federation
for american immigration reform
issued a tweet in the organization's
name denouncing the tragic carnage
and urging americans to quote stand
together against senseless rage and
destructive impulses
fair a leading proponent proponent of
restricting immigration
typically provides its 300 000 followers
on twitter and 2.1 million on facebook
with links to studies news stories and
podcasts
warning of the economic public safety
and environmental costs of high
immigration levels
but stein made no mention in his tweet
of the online document police believe
was written by the alleged killer which
cited many of the same arguments against
immigration
as a rationale and motivation for the
attack that killed 22 people
in a predominantly hispanic city near
the u.s mexico border now why exactly
would the head of fair
be tweeting out elements of the
manifesto he didn't write the manifesto
he doesn't support the manifesto
there's no evidence that he's a racist
there's no evidence that he's a white
supremacist
nonetheless the new york times overtly
links what is
by most like a mainstream conservative
anti-illegal immigration group
fair is more anti-immigration than i am
because they want to restrict legal
immigration too but
they are not a racist group and there's
no evidence provided in the piece that
they are
nonetheless the new york times goes out
of its way to link the
the right-wing views of the shooter on
immigration
to the right-wing views of this group on
immigration then suggest that the two
are equivalent
despite the fact that the shooter's
right-wing views were not just
right-wing they were actually white
supremacists right which is not
right-wing
white supremacism is something beyond
the racial solidarity implicit in white
supremacism
is not just about ensuring that
immigrants assimilate to american
culture it says no immigrants at all
because they're brown right it's a
completely different thing
stein's decision to rapidly issue a
statement condemning the el paso
massacre reflects a sense of alarm among
fair and the small cohort of other
restrictionist groups about potential
political fallout from the massacres
well yeah i mean number one they should
condemn
the shootings we should all condemn the
shooting but second of all maybe they
were worried about disingenuous
reporters at the new york times linking
them with the shooter and so they came
out and condemned the shooting
because they knew the new york times
would do it and then the new york times
did it anyway
long relegated to the fringes of the
debate these organizations have moved
censor stage under president trump
helping to provide the intellectual and
ideological framework for the
administration's hardline immigration
agenda
one that immigrant rights advocates have
decried as xenophobic and racist and
there you have it right
in the end there the new york times is
going to use as its
shield and as its sword immigration
rights groups
that basically posit exactly what david
nakamura wants them to posit which is
that immigration policy is racist and
xenophobic if it's not
open borders you're a white supremacist
if you disagree with the left
on immigration so the the left's
newfound attempt and many in the media
their newfound attempt to link
basic conservative policy with the el
paso shooting one of the reasons this is
going to have such dire effects
for american society is once you've
basically suggested that half of
americans
because half americans voted for trump
once you basically suggest that half of
americans
are actually nazis what do you think the
left is going to do
do you think that they are going to get
more reasonable in their conversation or
less reasonable in their conversation
once you overtly link ice to gestapo
tactics as sheila jackson lee did
do you think you're raising the
temperature or lowering the temperature
now i've been sort of positing the
the linkage i've been talking for for
years actually about the linkage between
rhetoric and violence and i've said
that i think that unless rhetoric
explicitly calls for violence
it is not incitement of violence that is
the legal standard in the united states
i will say however and i've said this
before that raising the temperature is
not good for the country
on its own merits so it's sort of like
the distinction between climate and
weather that we very frequently use when
we're talking about climate change
the climate is the generalized pattern
of weather over time right the the
climate is
over a certain period of time we can
expect the average to move up or down
based on particular factors weather is
specific events
as scientists generally say you cannot
mistake
weather for climate so you cannot say
that a hurricane is due to global
warming this specific hurricane is due
to
global warming you can say that there
are trends with regard to hurricanes
that may be due to global warming but
you can't say this specific hurricane
is due to global warming a weather event
is not a climate event
per se right a snowy a snowy day is not
evidence
that there is global cooling nor is a
super hot day evidence of global warming
well the same thing is true when it
comes to egregious acts
evil acts out of the out of the
statistical
norm acts like a shooting at this el
paso walmart
that is an act of weather it is not an
act of climate but raising the
climate changing the climate will have
impact on weather
inevitably and the left is having an
impact on this too the entire climate is
getting warmer the political climate is
getting warmer we are experiencing
political climate change right now
and we could we could lower the hot air
emissions coming from our mouths
we could lower the emissions that are
coming from our fingers out on twitter
we could lower the emissions by being
reasonable in how we castigate
our political opponents but instead we
are not doing this instead we are
deciding that we ought to ramp it up
and democrats are ramping it up at an
extraordinary rate
it really is truly incredible over on
msnbc they're making this clearest
donny deutsche host over on msnbc just
last night he suggested that every trump
supporter quote
owns the blood that happens and then you
expect that that's going to lower the
temperature that there's going to be
less violence there's going to be less
hatred
well done everyone people of color are
already targets under this
administration
i have no problem with shining the light
back on the donors
who fund this kind of of racialized
hate i want i mean i go further i want
pitchforks
and torches outside this man's house in
the hamptons i've been to the hamptons
it's very nice
there's no reason why it has to be
there's no reason why he should have his
night that she'd be
having a nice little party right no i
want people there's there's no reason
why people shouldn't be able to be
outside
of his house and making their
demonstrating totally
peacefully yes understood that they do
not they totally
rejected and stopped okay pitchforks and
torches
pitchforks and torches outside people's
house based on who they give money to
okay that wasn't donnie deutsch that's
illegal who's the executive editor of
above the law pitchforks and torches
outside of trump donors houses and then
there's an msnbc host i mentioned donnie
deutsch she says sort of the same thing
he says you own the blood that happens
as clip 18.
stephen ross to me is the epitome this
election comes down to guys like that
and people saying no you don't get to
say
um for racial equality and all these
good things
i disagree with him there but i like his
economic views i'm going to vote for no
you own it you own
the blood that happens you own
charlottesville you can't do it
you you get the whole package and that's
what swing voters
have got to understand and be shamed
into
you own the blood that happens we're
going to shame you into all of this okay
so the the radical democratic party and
many in the media are pushing this
including the new york times it's
amazing the new york times ran two
simultaneous pieces today
okay piece number one we're gonna get
into it in just one second piece number
one
okay from the new york times they say
trump's opponents want him to name
want to name his big donors his
supporters say it's harassment by katie
rogers and annie carney they start out
for many businesses a sudden deluge of
phone calls might signal an influx of
new customers
but most of the 25 calls justin
herrick's received before noon on
thursday
or from people who wanted to tell him he
was a white supremacist for donating
money to president trump
herrick's the owner of precision pipe
rentals an oil and gas services company
in san antonio said quote
i've had people say hey we're going to
use you for business but we found out
you're a racist
we hope you burn in hell and your
business will go with you the reason for
the calls was harris's inclusion this
week
on a list of 44 san antonio area
residents who have maxed out their
donations to the president's re-election
campaign
that list was shared on twitter by
representative joaquin castro a texas
democrat who serves as the chairman
of the presidential campaign of his twin
brother julian republicans have accused
the congressman
of doxing private citizens and trying to
incite harassment of the president's
supporters
now i find it hilarious that the new
york times which will simultaneously
claim that trump incited violence
will suggest that joaquin castro had no
role in inciting
harassment of businesses whose names he
tweeted out
and called them complicit in murder
effectively
so yeah i'm not gonna stand by your
standard of causation guys i think that
you've got this a little bit
mixed up the new york times has a
similar uproar over trump donors is
playing out in the moneyed enclave of
the hamptons
where real estate developers are hosting
two fundraisers for mr trump on friday
progressives looking for a way to
express their anger at mr trump and the
people who support him have threatened a
boycott soulcycle the popular spin
studio chain
and equinox a high-end gym both owned by
the billionaire developer steven ross
who's scheduled to host
the president calling out people who
fund campaigns is not a new tactic but
the question
of how much should be publicly disclosed
about those donors has been an issue
that republicans led by the senate
majority leader mitch mcconnell have
repeatedly raised
in recent years in a heated political
environment boycotting businesses of big
donors has led to a new round
of outrage at either end of the
political spectrum okay so the new york
times is openly acknowledging
that the people that joaquin castro
targeted are being harassed
so the new york times then has an
editorial from the editorial board
and it's called may the soul cycle
boycott make democracy better
and then they try to separate off what
joaquin castro did from what the people
boycotting soul cycle did
which is impossible because it's the
same exact thing right it is targeting
donors to political campaigns on the
basis of their politics
and then suggesting that they are
responsible for grave evil and no one
should patronize their businesses and
they deserve pitchforks and torches
outside their house it is the same exact
thing
the new york times is embarrassed that
joaquin castro
precipitated harassment of specific
people
but they kind of like his tactic and
that's what the editorial says they said
stunts like joaquin castro's upstage a
real concern
americans should want to know more about
who funds political campaigns um
we already have transparency laws in
place we already know who funds
political campaigns that's not what's
going on here
what is going on here is that when you
call trump a nazi and when you call his
supporters nazis and then you say here
are all the people who donate money to
nazis you should not be surprised
when the political climate change that
you are incurring
racks up and continues to rack up and
again i'm focusing it on the left today
because
the reactionary left is doing this this
week okay trump has raised the
temperature in the past and i have
ripped him a new one when he has
okay but the the raising the political
temperature from the left this week
has been utterly astonishing in the
aftermath of an attack that should at
least have brought us together for a
moment of mourning
when we're all on the same page with
regard to white supremacism
so the new york times editorial board
tries to tries to distinguish
the same movement to go after equinox
and soul cycle from what joaquin castro
did they said a popular form of protest
boycotts
more often served to draw public
attention to an issue than to affect
concrete change
with mr ross critics may or may not
manage to inflict any financial pain
they nonetheless are publicly demanding
that he answer for
and perhaps ultimately rethink his
political giving
in the process they're sending a signal
to other major contributors to carefully
consider
their choices lest they face a similar
accounting
public shaming seemed to be at the core
of mr castro's treat it well
though the outcry from republican
officials was much louder
the texas congressman was accused of
inviting harassment and encouraging
violence against
his own constituents there's rich irony
about the republican self-righteousness
then they say well it's kind of
embarrassing that that mr castro did
this
right they say that he unlinked
disclosure
from policy and that is a that is a bad
thing but then they conclude
by basically saying that we should
increase the amount of coverage of this
sort of stuff they say for now
one basic step maybe for media outlets
and other advocates for transparency
to keep working to ease access to and
promote interest in donor data more
broadly
so in other words we're embarrassed that
people harassed the people that were
targeted by joaquin castro let's do more
of that more of that would be good
the only problem is that castro said the
quiet part out loud
and that the people he targeted were the
little people but if they'd been the big
people
it would have been fine now listen i
think it is perfectly appropriate
to call out major donors for whom they
donate to
i do not think it is appropriate to
boycott businesses in which they invest
specifically because they happen to be
investors in that business
especially if the particularly and only
if the business does not reflect the
policy preferences of the person at the
top
so i don't know which businesses george
soros is invested as
i don't and frankly i don't really care
because as long as those businesses are
not reflecting his political preferences
i will shop there i think george soros
donates a lot of people to people i
really dislike i think that his politics
are egregiously bad in many many ways
really terrible in many ways i think he
funds a lot of groups that i really
can't stand
but i'm not going to stop shopping i i'm
not going to become part of a country
where everybody is expected and and must
in fact go through the corporate boards
of every major corporation
that produces a product that we eat wear
or entertain by
and then decide whether those people
reflect our politics by the way
important to note one of the major
funders of marvel entertainment is a
trump donor
so guys start start burning your
avengers end game
dvds well well this is all making the
country so much stronger
and so much better in the aftermath of
something as terrible as what just
happened the fact that we can't get
together on anything is really
indicative
of a serious problem in the country okay
in just a second
we're gonna get to democratic gun
control proposals and
joe biden making a big boo-boo on the
campaign trail we're also gonna get to
something that joe biden is doing right
that the other democrats are not doing
right first time is quickly
running out to purchase tickets to our
backstage live show it's a special one
night only event august 21st at the
beautiful terrace theater in long beach
california
i'll be there daily where godking jeremy
boring will be there andrew clavin
michael moles will be there if that's
something you want like herpes we'll be
talking politics
pop culture answering your questions
from the audience tickets are on sale
right now
at dailywire.com backstage including
those limited vip packages that got all
the media attention they guarantee
premium seating
photos meet and greets with each of us a
gift from me i've shopped for it for
it's beautiful
and more they're selling fast so head on
over to dailywire.com
backstage reserve yours today really the
tickets are gonna be gone probably by
next week so do it now
i'll see you there also our sunday
special this week
one of the reasons you should subscribe
is because you get our sunday special a
day
early and this week we have i think what
is a really fascinating and different
conversation
with the author jonathan safran foer so
you might know his work
in fiction everything is illuminated uh
he he's
he's done a lot of best-selling books
but he's also written non-fiction
specifically
about the morality of eating animals and
meat eating
and he has a new book that's coming out
in september all about
climate change he sort of makes the case
that we should eat less meat
in order to stop climate change i press
them on a little bit it's a really
interesting
and i think fun conversation something
completely different on our sunday
special here's a little bit of what it
sounds like
a lot of the ways that people talk about
making a difference are not making a
difference
they just feel good and i think in the
future
our children and our grandchildren our
great-grandchildren aren't going to look
back and say what did great grandpa ben
feel
and they're going to look back and say
what did great grandpa ben do
it's a really interesting conversation
you know i'm i'm as you know
skeptical of some of the claims that the
solutions purported to
be pushed by the global warming
extremist people like
aoc that those are going to either
accomplish what they seek to accomplish
or are practical in any possible way
but i also believe that climate change
is indeed happening i
agree with the general scientific
consensus that man-made
climate change is a huge part of the
problem
i disagree with a lot of the
prescriptions that are put out there
it's really
an interesting conversation you should
go check it out because i think it's
kind of more sophisticated than a lot of
the global warming
climate change conversations that you
generally hear out there also it is that
glorious time of the week when i give a
shout out to a daily wire subscriber
today
it's joseph lynch on instagram he has
one amazing view i mean that's a
terrific view
while enjoying a sip from the world's
greatest beverage vessel in the picture
joe apparently while sitting on his
motorcycle
is holding that leftist tears tumbler in
frame with mount rushmore looking down
upon him
and a fellow traveler the caption reads
cross country ride to toast the founders
with some leftist tears
hashtag leftist tears tumblr hashtag
combat veterans motorcycle association
awesome awesome stuff thank you joe for
your service in the us army and
continued
safe travels across this beautiful
country if you want that leftist year's
tumblr which is indeed magnificent
all you have to do is subscribe go
subscribe over at dailywire.com 99 bucks
a year gets you the tumblr
as well as the annual subscription and
all the goodies we are the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
again the left has has to make a
decision when we get to the broadening
out of the white supremacist label the
labeling of everybody on the right nazis
and complicit in nazism
the left has to make a decision and it's
a political decision as well as a moral
one the moral one is
do you really believe that your fellow
countrymen are
insidious racist nazis is that really
what you believe
do you really believe that this is 1859
or even
1960. is that is that what you really
believe when you look at your neighbors
is that what you see
when you look at a state that you don't
live in do you see
either godless leftists who hate america
on the one hand
or do you see a bunch of rube rednecks
you hate black people and gays on the
other
because if you're doing if that's what
you believe you're doing it wrong you
really are doing it wrong there are
serious differences in values in the
united states
but if the way we do politics is now to
label our opponents
as either incipient incipient
tyrants who are going to inevitably
destroy the republican all of our rights
or as people who are deliberately
attempting to harm black people and
brown people
and you lump in general policy with that
without any sort of
logical linkage you're doing it wrong
unfortunately the left is
doing this more and more now joe biden
actually is doing something
somewhat smart about this so joe biden
was asked yesterday joe biden is taking
a clever attack
politically so he says that trump
forwards white supremacy okay that is at
least an
arguable proposition on a logical point
of view because in 2015 2016 trump did
wink and not at the alt-right so that's
at least an
arguable proposition but joe biden is
not willing to call trump a white
supremacist why
because he understands that's number one
not true and number two that by
suggesting trump is a white supremacist
he is suggesting that all of trump's
supporters back a white supremacist so
biden
quite correctly is reluctant to go all
the way as we'll see his democratic
opponents are not
i believe everything the president says
has done encourages white supremacists
and i'm not sure there's much of a
distinction as a matter of fact it may
be even worse
in fact if you're out there trying to in
fact
curry the favor of white supremacists or
any group that in fact is
anathema to everything we believe so
whether he is or is not a white
supremacist
he encourages them everything he does he
speaks to them
he's afraid to take them on and if you
notice the one time he used the word
white supremacy
he was uh you know it was not was he
talked about sleepy
he was awful sleepy in the way in which
he talked about okay so
he's he's making the distinction now he
should be making the distinction more
strongly and obviously he's exaggerating
the president's record on white
supremacy by a long shot
again the president has condemned trump
has condemned white supremacy
about a thousand times since 2017. with
that said he's doing something other
democrats are not doing right elizabeth
warren just came straight out and she
tweeted out that the president is a
white supremacist
right she actually tweeted out today i
was asked whether the president is a
white supremacist
i said yes okay good luck with that
pitch good luck with the pitch that
trump is white supremacist first of all
it's obvious bs everyone knows it
second of all you're labeling everyone
who supports him a supporter of white
supremacism
and what this is leading the radical
left to do is to polarize the debate
in a wild and crazy way so i want to
give you an example of how terrible
the media are in covering this sort of
polarization
so tommy lee who's the founding member
of
motley crew long long time drummer and
of course star of a sex tape with pamela
anderson most famously
tommy lee put out a statement on twitter
that he cribbed from somebody else
on on reddit here is the statement
that he put out on twitter quote you
trumpsters better pray that liberals
never gain control of the white house
again
because we are going to pay you pay you
back so effing hard
for all of this s word planned
parenthood's on every damn corner
we're gonna repaint air force one
hat pink and fly it over your beloved
bible belt six days a week tossing birth
control pills condoms and atheist
literature from the cockpit
we're to tax your mega churches so bad
joel osteen will need to get a job
at chick-fil-a to pay his light bill
speaking of chick-fil-a we're buying all
those
and giving them to any lgbtq person your
sick cult leader is tortured with
conversion therapy
have fun with the new menu you bigoted f
words try the mcpens it's a boiled
unseasoned chicken breast that you have
to eat in the closet with your mother
we're going to gather up all your guns
melt them down and turn them into a
gargantuan metal mountain
emblazoned with the face of hillary
clinton all parks will be renamed rosa
parks
asap we're replacing confederate statues
with blm leaders and mexican immigrants
every single public school will be
renamed after a child that was kidnapped
by this regime
and after we fumigate the white house
we're repainting the whole thing rainbow
fox news will be taken over and turned
into a family refugee shelter
we're turning hannity's office into a
giant unisex bathroom with changing
tables and free tampons
and every single time a trumpster
complains about any of the changes we're
adding an openly gay character to a
disney movie
okay so it's obviously an insane
ridiculous post that is
specifically designed to take off the
right obviously it's trollery it's
rollery
let me redo the headlines and how this
is covered now imagine first of all that
this had been
somebody a trumpster posting this from
the right we're going to
we are going to seize your birth control
we are going to turn this into the
hands-maid tale
every time you complain about it we are
going to force you to bear a trial right
imagine the the right-wing reversal of
this like a right-wing fascist reversal
of what tommy lee
is doing here imagine the headlines from
a prominent person
career over right career done obviously
here are the headlines
here are the headlines from the various
newspapers
people magazine tommy lee reshares
explosive rant
that lays into donald trump wow what
what a hero
what a hero usa today an unapologetic
tommy lee
lays aim at the trumpsters the daily
beast no tommy lee is not a fan of
president trump
complex tommy lee strikes a nerve by
sharing quote that envisions a
post-trump america
new york daily news motley crue drummer
takes tommy lee
takes aim at trump supporters
okay i mean this is aol.com tommy lee
rise up from
riles up trumpsters with lengthy
political message on social media
variety tommy lee slams trump in twitter
rant
and then you wonder why people in
conservative america are getting a
little frustrated let's see you're
calling us all nazis and white
supremacists
and meanwhile you are treating with kid
gloves
a rant in which a person threatens to
establish abortion clinics on every
corner
the takeover of all right-wing
businesses right-wing owned businesses
conservative-owned businesses
the the destruction of our culture
wholesale
and that's celebrated by the media
well done on ramping down the
polarization here guys you're doing a
fantastic fantastic job seth bullock
the governor of montana at least he
seems to understand that this is a real
problem that the democratic party the
media
at the left are out of control he says
listen we're going to lose this election
we keep going this way
please permit me to take everyone out of
the twitterverse
for at least a minute and bring us back
to earth
let me put it plainly we cannot defeat
donald trump's politics of personal
destruction if we practice the politics
of self-destruction the fact is
we are well on our way to losing this
election
long before it ever really even has
started
okay well you know the they're not going
to take us they're not going to take
them seriously they're not taking
anybody seriously
on the on the left like they are they're
ignoring every good piece of advice they
have ever received
and meanwhile they're pushing further
and further on policy and
this is the other half of the coin the
other side of the coin is that it's not
just democrats castigating republicans
as nazis it's also them pushing policies
that are wildly unpalatable to the vast
majority of americans so take for
example andrew cuomo the governor of new
york so he came out yesterday
and he endorsed a bevy of gun control
measures some of these measures are
patently crazy
i'm asking all democrats or democrats
who want to run for president and come
into the state of new york
just make it a simple clear choice for
the american people
the make america safer
pledge four elements
an assault weapon ban high capacity
magazines
universal background check mental health
database red flag laws
those four elements of gun control will
change
this nation those four elements of gun
control will change so
red flag laws are something that i've
talked about gun violence restraining
orders and if properly drawn they might
be a good idea but
creating a mental health database how's
that even going to work
i mean really how's that going to work
like you suffer from depression and go
see a therapist and so now you're banned
from from
accessing guns like under any
circumstances that's not orwellian
at all that's not that's not violative
passing universal background checks we
have them in california they have not
accomplished anything outlawing quote
unquote assault weapons and
high-capacity
magazines again california has done the
high-capacity magazine outlawing it
hasn't done
anything we've had multiple mass
shootings in california since that has
happened
the assault weapons ban from 1994 to
2004 had no effect
so this is these policies are not in
line with what most americans want
and then it gets worse right joe biden
yesterday speaking in iowa
he says his first move as president of
the united states would be to rejoin the
paris climate accord which by the way is
a completely
eff effect-free climate accord
it doesn't actually create obligations
on any of the countries the number one
reduction in climate
emissions happened in the united states
after we pulled out of the paris climate
accord
so it has nothing to do with anything
real but according to joe biden it's
first priority
you know i love the fact that there is
no global warming you all know that out
here in iowa
you know it doesn't exist i heard a
farmer today on the tv
who's a republican said well i don't
think it's caused by humans but i have a
problem
i have a problem well there's a big
problem this is the existential threat
to the united states to the world and
it's real
and it's not it's not just uh
11 years we've got about 10 years before
we lose the opportunity
to stop the erosion that's occurring now
it's real
first thing i would do as president
united states i'd rejoin the paris
climate accord which i helped put
together
stumbling and bumbling and bumbling and
stumbling his way around the campaign
trail speaking of which joe biden had a
major stumble
yesterday on the campaign trail and it's
fun to watch the left
simultaneously depending on whether they
like biden or not ignore it or make a
big deal out of it
in reality it's just trump it's just
biden stumbling over his words like he
regularly does but listen to biden he's
talking about education
and in this clip you're going to hear
him equate poor people with black people
and smart people and smart and rich
people with white people it's pretty
wild
we should challenge students in these
schools to have advanced placement
programs in these schools
we have this notion that somehow if
you're poor you cannot do it
poor kids are just as bright and just as
tall as white kids
wealthy kids black kids asian kids
and then i like how he tries to walk it
back because he realizes what he said
in real time now let's put it this way
if donald trump had ever said anything
like that that leads the news for a week
right
because the media have a narrative and
the narrative is that if trump makes a
gaffe
it is in line with his underlying racism
and racial animus
if joe biden who once declared that
every 7-eleven has an indian person
behind the counter
apparently he got that from watching the
simpsons or something it's ridiculous
that same joe biden if he says that poor
kids are basically
black and white kids are rich
then that's totally fine most members of
the media been trying to walk this off
now in fairness do i think that joe
biden actually believes that all poor
kids in the united states are black
no i don't i don't i think this is joe
biden messing all over himself because
he does that on a regular basis and
that's why he has to wear political
depends the political depends are the
members of the media but
the but that's not going to stop members
of his own party from going after him
the woke brigade so
bill de blasio who is insufferable on
the highest level he tweeted out
about joe biden and this is this is a
let them fight from godzilla moment
bill de blasio tweets out poor kids are
just as bright and talented as white
kids
to merely dismiss joe biden's words as a
mere slip of the tongue
is as concerning as what he said we need
to have a real conversation about the
racism and sexism behind electability
so now bill de blasio is making the case
that if you talk about electability
you're racist
and if you're a democrat who thinks joe
biden is more electable it's because you
think joe biden is more
racially friendly to the vast bevy of
racist white folks across america so
electability is code for
you're racist i mean if this doesn't
give the lie
to what the left and the democrats on
the radical left are doing
i don't know what does it's just a
matter of degree the mainstream media
are trying to declare that if you are
strong at immigration policy you're
racist
the more woke democrats are trying to
declare
that if you ever gave money to donald
trump or give money to donald trump
mainstream democrats even are doing this
then you are a racist and a vicious
bigot
the most woke democrats like galaxy
brain the most galaxy brain democrats
like bill de blasio
are claiming that joe biden is a racist
the galaxy brains like aoc nancy pelosi
is a racist aoc said that the new york
times was racist
so it's only a matter of degree and then
you wonder why people don't take your
adjudications of racism seriously guys
maybe it's because it's only a matter of
degree in how you're going to misuse the
label
because you never actually define the
label it's it's really
it's a bad move by by democrats
politically and it's really really bad
for the country failing to define terms
deliberately obfuscating clarity
deliberately
overriding overriding reality in order
to pursue a narrative is dangerous
dangerous stuff and meanwhile a piece of
news that the media will largely ignore
a good guy with a gun stopped a bad guy
with a gun
over in kentucky or rather in
springfield missouri according to
kentucky 3 the springfield police
department says it responded to a call
of an active shooter
at the walmart neighborhood market at
republic road near golden avenue on
thursday evening
the springfield police department
arrived on scene within three minutes of
the call
police stated that a young white male
appearing to be in his 20s pulled up to
the walmart where he donned body armor
and military fatigues
police say that the man had tactical
weapons he walked into the walmart
he grabbed a cart and began pushing it
around the store police say the man was
recording himself walking through the
store via a cell phone
the store manager at the neighborhood
market pulled a fire alarm urging people
to escape the store
the man then made his way out of an
emergency exit where a former
firefighter held the man at gunpoint
so a firefighter not a police officer a
firefighter who had a concealed carry
permit held the guy at gunpoint
at that moment springfield police
arrived on scene and detained the man
the springfield pd could not confirm the
nature of the statement said by the man
to those inside walmart
they do confirm the man had loaded
weapons and over 100 rounds
of ammunition lieutenant mike lucas said
it was clear the man's intent was to
cause chaos
he said his intent was not to cause
peace or comfort he's lucky to be alive
still to be honest
police identified the man's vehicle for
all the talk about how
good guys with guns don't happen good
guys with guns
do happen and that is a pretty obvious
case of a good guy with a gun okay it's
a friday so it's time to do a little bit
of mailbagging so let's mail bag it up
let's see abraham says a few weeks ago
you tried to answer my question about
the long-term sustainability of trade
deficits
the thing is i've often heard your
grocery store analogy but i see a flaw
suppose the sum total of all your
outside shopping exceeded all of your
outside income
wouldn't you go broke eventually your
answer that china invests in us bonds or
u.s companies
means that you agree that in the end it
winds up as u.s debt or foreign
ownership of our assets
how is that sustainable over time well
it is sustainable
over time given that they are going to
have to buy from you so that that
actually you answered your own question
to go back to the the grocery store
analogy let's say you spend all of your
money at the grocery store
and the grocery store only spends some
of its money with you
but then the grocery store can only
spend you currency
right you have your own currency so the
grocery store can only spend the u-bucks
with you so the grocery store goes in
and they buy some of your assets or they
buy something that you want
one of two things is eventually going to
happen right eventually what you're
going to end up with is the grocery
store
will no longer be able to buy your
assets because you won't have any more
assets
and thus you will be forced not to spend
in those countries
presumably at the grocery store or
alternatively the grocery store will
keep taking your money and keep buying
stuff from you
right the the long-term ownership of u.s
assets
there's a lot of worry about this with
japan in the 1980s it turns out that
trade deficits usually are not sustained
on a year-to-year basis they fluctuate
so sometimes there's a trade deficit
sometimes there is not a trade deficit
if you ran a trade deficit forever
eventually countries
might stop investing in you if they
found nothing worth investing in but
they're really not cases that i can
think of
offhand that where this has been the
case where there's been a continued
forever trade deficit and people stop
investing with you because they just
won't take your money anymore
ariel says hey ben love your show i'm a
new mother to a soon-to-be one-year-old
you often talk about the importance of
raising kids with healthy boundaries and
rules
i was curious about what you think are
some imperative rules and boundaries to
have in the home to raise healthy
children
thanks for all your hard work well you
know i'm i'm working on this the same
as you are i'm a five-year-old and a
three-year-old and
the imperative rules and boundaries well
number one
no hitting if you have more than one no
hitting express yourself
whining doesn't get you anything in fact
whining gets things taken away from you
you you have to wait right patience
would be a big one
frustr fighting frustration in kids is
very difficult because they can't really
express themselves a lot of the time
so you have to be patient with them but
bad behavior does not earn extra
attention
this is the easiest mistake to make i've
made it before obviously most parents
have
that is your kid is whining your kid is
bothering you it's easier just to give
them the cookie
than to fight the whining my problem is
you've now trained your kid to whine to
get cookies
so you really do have to fight that
instinct in yourself to just say god
this is such a pain in the ass here's
the cookie
it's very difficult thomas says hey ben
i was curious if you thought that the
democrats run to the left is about more
than just the makeup of the primary
voting base
is there also a degree of confidence
that trump is so unpopular he will lose
no matter what and that running to the
left will allow them to claim a mandate
for their far-left policies
well i do think that there is some of
this i think that the democrats
have convinced themselves that trump is
wildly unpopular
and they therefore believe that they can
run as far left as they want to run
and so the the they are mistaking
trump's personal unpopularity
with the unpopularity of his political
program and that's a huge mistake that's
that's not
backed by poles of reality christopher
says hey ben
absolutely love your show listen to the
whole three hours daily appreciate it
have even have my kids yelling at my
parents who only watched cnn the ben
shapiro show
this is a six-year-old and four-year-old
mind you anyway i live in australia
sometimes i wish i lived in the u.s as
long as the leftists aren't running the
show my question
is around my parents they're adamant
that trump is writing a good economy
which was set up by obama
i'm not sure of good arguments against
this is there any policy in which you
suggest i should bring up and facts
behind them to prove that in fact trump
is the reason behind the strong economy
well
again i think it's actually more
complicated economics is more
complicated than who is president
so there's a good case to be made that
bill clinton was riding off the back of
a strong reagan economy
it is much easier for the president of
the united states to quell economic
growth than to create economic growth
what the markets generally look for is
predictability in
the in in stability in sort of the
background noise of the economy meaning
they know what's going to happen
tomorrow now what you could point to is
the fact that the
gdp growth rates under barack obama were
very low on average
around two percent range for most of the
recovery
that lasted from about 2009 all the way
up to
the present but the fact is that those
gdp rates accelerated dramatically in
year one under the trump administration
that was due to deregulation it was due
to the tax cuts
again i i'm always loath to suggest that
the president of the united states of
any party
is able to just jog the economy with his
policies inevitably
but a president can certainly hurt the
economy with his policies and barack
obama did quell growth
by raising taxes by increasing
regulations by creating a less friendly
business environment there are other
ways in which
in which obama's trade policies for
example were actually more free and open
than some of the stuff that trump has
been pushing and that's why you're
starting to see the economy slow right
now because of the back of chinese
tariffs
andre says hey ben i'm an immigrant from
colombia holds the same views as you do
on immigration
most recently i had a close friend of
mine who's a teacher talk about students
she has who have had their parent or
relative arrested and deported and how
much it has affected them in a negative
way
her post was very emotional and appealed
to people's humanity how do you respond
to such emotional stories without
compromising
on what the real solutions should be and
without sounding like you don't care at
all
honestly i i do care i mean i think that
of course i feel terrible for a student
who's had their parent deported
the question really is whether for a
country
sympathy alone is enough of a rationale
for allowing immigrants into your
country
the question is why the parent was
deported i don't have enough information
to know was the parent deported
simply because the parent was here
illegally and the parent let's say
was working without taking government
benefits it was a benefit to the
community and assimilating
in that case i think that person should
have a pathway to citizenship right my
my view on immigration has always been
that we ought to treat people like
individuals the same way that we treat
people like individuals under the law in
the united states generally
treating people by class is usually a
large scale mistake
now if the person was deported because
they committed a crime because they were
on welfare and because they were taking
taxpayer dollars because they'd come
here illegally without the permission of
the us government
and cut people in line i don't have a
lot of sympathy for the parent i have
sympathy for the kid but the parent put
the kid in that position by legally
immigrating that's not the us
government's fault
we should we should try to figure out a
way where families can come in
together to be of benefit to the united
states so we have to regularize our
immigration
process but none of that forecloses
sympathy for the kid it's not the kid's
fault of course i feel terrible
for the child john says hi ben a couple
weeks ago you mentioned that if joe
biden does not get the 2020 nomination
the democratic party will irreversibly
turn even more radical than they already
are
do you think that in the future the
party will just go further and further
to the left
or do you think it will cease to exist
at some point i wonder about this since
the democratic party appears
indistinguishable from other groups like
the socialist or green parties
thanks a lot for your thoughts have a
great day as i've said many times i
don't think that
either party is poised to disappear i do
think that
both parties have moved steadily to the
left particularly on issues of spending
and regulation
and i think that more and more
we are going to see the parties co-opted
from forces inside the parties the
democratic party will just become the
green party effectively speaking
it won't be that it just disappears and
the green party replaces it
i think that if i had to forecast
politics for the next 20 years
basically over the next 20 years the
democratic party will become the green
party and the republican party
as it has been want to do will continue
to slide to the left on spending to the
point where it now matches where the
democratic party is
because the republican party on spending
now is where the democratic party was on
spending
in like 2005. it's pretty pretty
ridiculous clyde says ben
in episode 18 you state that an
atheistic society does not give you a
reason to live
i disagree in an atheistic society a
reason to live might be to be successful
and enjoy life
well again i'm not saying that person
that atheists on an individual level
can't find a reason to live i'm saying
that a society that is based
on godlessness that is based on an idea
that you are purposelessly here in the
universe on the john paul
idea you're here purposelessly in the
universe that you have
no free will you're a ball of meat
wandering through space
that your life has no innate value above
that of any animal life
i'm not sure how that grants a sense of
purpose to anybody
um on a broad scale i mean you can find
one but you have to ignore some of the
premises of your own philosophy
and what you can do i mean people live
like this all the time cognitive
dissonance wonderful thing
there are people and the same thing
holds true in the realm of morality i
know many atheists are more moral people
than many of the religious people i know
so i'm not talking about the individual
level really i'm talking about if you
are going to create a societal system
that create that inculcates purpose and
virtue in people
very hard to do that from an atheistic
materialist basis
now i think that you can be an atheist
without being a scientific materialist
but i'm wondering
how you get to the notions of free will
the notions of virtue and morality how
you go from
human beings are basically an
evolutionary creation created by
by randomness mutated over the course of
generations to deal with the environment
how do you get from that to morality
or purposefulness in life
let's see and if you want to know more
about this clive you can check out my
book the right side of history
largely about this topic dylan says hey
ben i work at a liberal university
managing public health telephone surveys
i recently have been working on a
project that requires data collection in
both english and spanish both of which i
speak
however i came upon information that
planned parenthood is a stakeholder
in the project being vehemently pro-life
i feel as though i can't collect data on
this project
and should speak with my boss what would
you recommend so the
question really is when says they're a
stakeholder in the project do they
benefit from the project
and is it affecting how the project is
done meaning if you are gathering
information
on behalf of planned parenthood then
you're working for planned parenthood
right this is not quite the same thing
as boycotting equinox
where the person making money on the
other end doesn't actually control the
government policy
right it doesn't have to do with how the
business is run if that person if
stephen ross who ran equinox was running
a get out the vote effort
then boycotting to get out the vote
effort seems to me perfectly reasonable
if effectively what you're talking about
is a get out the vote effort for planned
parenthood then
going in and saying you don't want to be
part of it that seems reasonable to me
let's see nathan says ben love the show
and everything you do live in the dc
area and work the department of defense
i hear a dozen different and probably
useless explanations on chinese currency
manipulation
wondering if you can give the elevator
speech on the topic and offer a book
paper something that can delve deeper
into the topic
thanks again nate well when it comes to
currency manipulation you know i'm i'm
always a fan of the
sort of classical viennese economists
folks like frederick hayek
folks like mices right they they write
about
currency manipulation and its curses
repeatedly as i've told you before as
i've said before
i am a fan of the gold standard in which
the government doesn't get to manipulate
the level of currency when it comes to
chinese currency manipulation
what people are worried about is that
china is going to radically inflate its
currency
and in doing so it's going to make it
very hard for the united states to
import product into china and very easy
for china to export products to the
united states now in the long run
devaluing your currency like that
actually hurts your own citizens because
now they're getting more and more
expensive products and their savings are
worth nothing
right so devaluing currency is not
actually good for a country
over any significant period of time but
when it comes to trade wars devaluing
your currency
sometimes allows you to pay back debts
with the devalued currency sometimes it
allows you to
export products quote unquote more
cheaply because the exchange rate
has just changed dramatically now i
am not sure that chinese currency
manipulation is behind what is currently
going on in china so people have been
saying that china is manipulating its
currency right now to inflate it
that seems to me quite plausibly the
after effects of american tariffs
against china
because when we tariff the chinese
government what we are actively doing
is up valuing our own currency we're
putting less american dollars into
circulation which means there are fewer
of them available which means that the
demand stays the same the supply is
lowered the price of an american dollar
goes up
this means an immediate devaluation of
the chinese currency just as a natural
consequence of america placing tariffs
on chinese goods
but labeling them and currency
manipulator allows us to take different
trade actions against them
again not clear that that's a good idea
also not clear that it's actually
an effective evaluation of the situation
okay let's see maybe one more question
michael says
hey ben serious question what would it
take to turn the star wars franchise
around for you with the upcoming rise of
skywalker film
um it was all a dream it was all a dream
would be the best possible solution
i think that we would probably at this
point have to redo all of it
it turns out that killing off all of
your childhood heroes and making them
losers was a very bad idea
and there's this line in the last jedi
where kylo ren
turns to rey and says why can't we just
erase
all of the past and then we'll start new
you and me and it's a really interesting
moment
and ray's like no we can't do that we
can't do that okay the problem is that
disney is actually kylo ren
so they've bought they've taken all the
nostalgia that you had for your
childhood watching the star wars movies
and then they have killed off every one
of those characters one by one
to benefit characters who are
significantly less interesting on every
possible level
it's terrible i mean i'm still i blame
jj abrams i think this all star
i'm not going to blame ryan johnson as
the as the true
creator of the star wars collapse jj
abrams is a derivative
b movie director and he directed the the
he directed episode what was it seven he
directed episode seven
with all of the creativity of a
plagiarist
hey look a death star i'm shocked hey
look it's a guy who's kind of cut he's
just basically darth vader
that's amazing but he created a great
sin the great sin as i've said before
is that he took han solo who was the
coolest character in the original star
wars
and turned him into a loser divorce dad
who wanders around the universe in his
cadillac with the shot
with the fuzzy dice and his best friend
smoking weed
and then shows up only to be killed by
his son at the behest of his wife he
hasn't seen in 20 years
for the dumbest possible reason at that
point i was like out
sorry i'm out so you know i think that
what would it take to to make this
happen well it would take to
honestly what would take to make this
more interesting and creative would be
for
there to be a sort of mixture of the
light and dark side there's been talk
about this
that maybe ray unifies the light and the
dark and that was sort of the move that
kylo ren was making in the last
movie that would have been interesting
they were actually honestly like 15
seconds away
from making that movie really
fascinating and that was kylo ren and
ray joining forces
right that would have been fascinating
and then the tension between them like
what they really should have done is
they should have allowed rey to move
with
kylo ren and then they should have had
the original star wars characters
because at that point luke is still
alive and should have had the original
star wars characters
then fighting against the newbies right
that would have been fascinating and
really counterintuitive because
honestly let's be real about this who
cares about kylo ren and ray like just
your sympathies don't lie with them your
sympathies were always with the original
characters because you have 40 years of
nostalgia for those characters
stupid stupid stupid okay so
here's my proposal my proposal is we
pretend that these movies never happened
it was all a dream
and then we either recast all of the
original parts and pick up right where
return of the jedi left off with the
admiral thrawn still out there trying to
reunite the fragments of the empire
or we fast forward 70 years everybody's
dead there are statues of them in the
great hall
and you just move on with whatever the
universe is instead they decided to
have the baby and you ended up with the
worst of all possible scenarios
alrighty so we're not going to do things
i like or things i hate today because
we're just out of time but
gang our business is growing rapidly
that means that we are excited to be
offering more opportunities to become
part of our in-house team
head on over to dailywire.com careers
see if any of our job openings would be
right for you or somebody that you know
i know i make it sound horrible to work
here and that's because it is i mean
just ask any of our producers but
if you actually do want to work here and
be part of the
the gulag like slog through the mud that
is working at the daily wire you can
make that happen by going over to
dailywire.com
careers we eagerly await making you
into one of our low paid scullions
enjoy check us out at dailywire.com
careers also please subscribe as always
we're here for two more hours later this
afternoon otherwise we'll see you here
on monday i'm ben shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
robert sterling directed by mike joyner
executive producer jeremy boring senior
producer jonathan haye
our supervising producer is mathis
glover and our technical producer is
austin stevens
edited by adam syavitz audio is mixed by
mike coromina
hair and makeup is by jessua olvera
production assistant nick sheehan the
ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production
copyright daily wire 2019. hey guys over
on the mat wall show today republicans
and democrats are both now pushing for
gun control they want something called a
red flag law but what is a red flag law
and is it a good idea we'll try to
answer those questions today
also joe biden once again embarrasses
himself in hilarious fashion and
the left seeks vengeance we'll talk
about all that today
and more on the matt walsh show